[Music]
coming up on 5 16 on your friday morning
hey middle school kids showing poise and
grace and curiosity on their tour of
eight news now
before we said goodbye to the students
as they wrapped up their visit learning
all about what it takes to do
media work their teacher david wright
told us that while the bells and
whistles in our building are cool i love
going into the you know spaceship in the
back the control room being in front of
a camera is nothing new for them on a
daily basis these students come to
school an hour early to help film our
fest flicks daily that's our daily news
production they're 6th 7th and 8th grade
students the book fair is finally open
but sadly only for teachers today we
gave them a chance to be junior weather
buddies humidity is 17
the dew point is 31 degrees and the
sunset is supposed to be at 7 32 pm how
cool is that
thanks again to their teacher mr wright
and to jen rochford here at the station
for showing the kids around if you know
something that's cool at school let us
know cool it's cool under the community
tab at eight news now or just send us an
email cool at school at eightnewsnow.com
and you are mentioning heather that not
only did the kids enjoy themselves and
show a lot of curiosity they were very
thankful they were so grateful and they
sent emails which i was just you know
just astonished by that great very kind
i think we need a new stance yeah i mean
those kids had a pose they had really
cool like graphics like you know
i want that and they do have their own
youtube channel with their daily
festflix newscast the daily
announcements that john you were saying
that we didn't have that when we were in
school
we would just stand in the middle of the
quad and just bark out what was on lunch
the menu today and that was it